I mean moments after the swim you just
got off the seats right yeah I literally
just sit I was balling a second ago I
thought it up real quick but with it
where you gonna keep your Grammy
I don't currently have a home so no have
you talked to the guys yet I did yeah we
definitely we called each other and
freaks out yeah I mean we were so
nervous so that's really making us more
nervous to be honest yeah I mean I mean
we got we got some confidence but then
you kind of when you win something you
realize like the gravity of what the
actual reward is and I mean we're really
excited but so how'd you get the news
did she call you did we're people
texting you we were like watching the
live feed thing pretty religiously and
of course stuck in LA traffic but we
were the [ __ ] friend we did a little
bit this morning you know I've gotta
settle the nerves somehow absolutely
so how's dating is it for you to be here
tonight not the most exciting I mean
this is like the biggest award show for
music period you know and as musicians
we worked really hard on everything so
to come here you know as a nominee it
just means everything to us so win or
lose it's like you kind of just feel
like you already won just being a part
of this blowing up the chart all year
long but not an official full-length
album yeah that's coming this year right
now we're ready we got a full album it's
gonna be amazing
it's coming out April 7 okay anyway it's
coming out really soon oh that's called
memories do not open